we'll all fly away together one last
time the completion of James Gunn's
Guardians Trilogy has some truly
heartbreaking moments but one death was
seriously naughty we were expecting keep
watching to find out who that was we've
known for a long while that the Grim
Reaper has been sharpening its side the
head of Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3.
historically James Gunners killed card
says if the reason is good and has done
so in both previous Guardians movies the
original Groot in the first one and Yan
doing Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2.
what's more gun dropped the huge volume
3 bombshell about another impending
character death way back in 2020 so fans
have had plenty of time to think about
the Guardians characters who are most
likely to die well Gunn certainly wasn't
lying Guardians of the Galaxy volume 3
features plenty of death from the almost
casual end of sovereign leader Aisha to
the latest civilization the high
evolutionary destroys however fans who
have been bracing themselves for the
death of a century Guardian character
could walk away from the movie relieved
or disappointed depending on your
outlook despite multiple extremely close
calls the Heroes all survived the movie
and even get a happy ending to their
various character arcs well that doesn't
mean the movie doesn't feature a
particularly grueling death though it
just starts instead of killing off a
familiar name volume 3 opts to establish
a new likable character for this purpose
in what just might be the most emotional
moment in a movie that's Chuck full of
them the high evolutionary guns Lila
down at the beginning of Rocket's Escape
Plan it's a pivotal moment in both the
movie and Rocket's life and though we've
only known Lila for a few scenes her
death and its impact on Rocket is
nothing short of devastating it can be
difficult to Market a movie in a way
that attracts potential viewers yet
doesn't give away too much of the plots
and the big beats because of this
promotional material has to straddle a
fine line and the end result isn't
always successful in fact there are many
trailers that game way too much of the
movie Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 on
the other hand takes a different
approach while the movie itself enjoys
debating the viewer with numerous close
calls when it comes to carrot to death
the trailers deceive the viewer in the
opposite way when it comes to Lila
Marvel fans might go into the movie with
the knowledge that Lila and Rocket have
quite a happy storyline in the comics
definitely happier than what they get in
the movie
as search from the promotional materials
see the adorable utter embracing rocket
or laughing on the floor it's all too
easy to take these fleeting moments of
Happiness as a sign of a happy reunion
for current Day Rocket
in reality however the movie takes a
stark turn for the worst at the moment
the happy hug from the trailers happens
barely a second after this familiar
moment the high evolutionary ruthlessly
shoots Lila in the back and proceeds to
mock rocket as if things weren't already
bad enough floor and thieves perish in
the chaos that ensues from the shooting
and Rockets attack on the high
evolutionary leaving the enhanced
raccoon while and truly alone in the
world
sure Lily wrote a relatively minor
character in the grand scheme of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe however her
influence on Rocket's life the shocking
circumstances of her death and the
immediate face ripping Devastation
rocket and leeches in retaliation add up
to one of the most impactful death
scenes in the franchise